Speaker 1: . I realized yesterday that it's
not just some on the left who would rather
not hear any more about Donald Trump.
It's also some on the right, some actual Trump
who simply want us to forget about the things
that Donald Trump did on the left.
Many people are just sick of Donald Trump,
and that's understandable.
Many on the left want there to never be another
Donald Trump in power.
And I'm with you 100 percent.
But as I've said before, pretending that Donald
Trump doesn't still, at least for now, control
the Republican Party would be factually inaccurate.
It would not be based in reality.
We would do ourselves a disservice by not
recognizing that.
But there is another side to this.
Ah, well, Mandawuy wrote a really good piece
in The Guardian called Trump's Enablers want
us to forget what they did.
We can't let that happen.
And in this article, Arwa accurately points
out, listen, Donald Trump made one point six
billion dollars personally during his four
years as president.
His family profited handsomely from the presidency.
I could list the individual atrocities for
hours, you know, suggesting the injection
of bleach to treat covid lying about him,
separating himself from his businesses on
and on and on.
But Arwa points out something really important,
which is that by ignoring these horrible people
when they leave office, we have already allowed
many of them to at least partially successfully
rehabilitate their images and the perception
of their time in office.
John Boehner is an example.
John Boehner now has a memoir where he criticizes
George W. Bush and is now doing some lobbying
for cannabis legalization.
And there are people who are now starting
to see John Boehner less unfavorably or more
favorably than than they once did.
But John Boehner admits that actually he voted
for Donald Trump.
He enabled lots of the things that he criticizes
George W. Bush for.
He shouldn't be allowed to rehabilitate himself.
George W. Bush himself, who now appears on
Ellen DeGeneres Show, is friends with Ellen,
paints his paintings and all this stuff.
He was a horrifying war criminal.
Yes, he was notably and cartoonishly he was
slightly less notably in cartoonishly unhinged
than Trump, but he was absolutely and completely
horrible.
And what happens, as Arwa Medowie points out,
is that when you start ignoring them because
they're gone and you're happy that they're
gone, which is understandable, that part makes
sense.
They start publishing the memoirs to rewrite
history.
They become known for the best or the most
benign elements of their past, rather than
the absolutely disgusting and monumental things
that they did.
You sort of need, quite frankly, a continued
narrative about their atrocities to prevent
that rehabilitation from happening.
And that is how we get to the Trump.
Don't want Trump remembered for inciting the
January 6th riots for his total failure on
coronavirus, for the disastrous response to
the Puerto Rican hurricane, for giving classified
information to foreign officials, including
a Russian spy recruiter in the Oval Office
for his love affairs.
With various authoritarians around the world.
As we talked about earlier on in the show,
you may have already forgotten about some
of these things, and it's only been a few
months.
Trump demonized immigrants, but so did George
W. Bush.
Do people remember that?
Is that part of the narrative or has Bush
successfully rehabilitated himself enough?
Where we no longer think about that?
There is a sort of straight line, as Arwa
writes from all of these people.
As I've said before and I talked about on
Monday, you can go, you know, Reagan, Gingrich,
Bush, Trump, and with many others in between.
So the right also has an interest in defining
how Trump is remembered or not remembered.
And that's another part of the reason why
we can't allow the absurdity and the insanity
to be forgotten and where Trump is different
in the sense that he's, you know, a different
age out of office.
He's older, out of office than some others
have been.
He seems less aware in a particular way of
how to rehabilitate his.
It may be a different thing, but it's important
to remember that as much as we are glad Trump
is gone, the right has a significant interest,
even potentially so that Trump can run again
in twenty twenty four in us forgetting what
Donald Trump was important not to forget it.